hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Lyme disease molecular
diagnostics and detection of new
causative agents presented by dr. Bobby
prick
I'm Cindy Valdez of lab routes and I
will be your moderator for today's
events we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone for this this presentation is
interactive we want to hear from you so
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we will
make sure to follow up with you by email
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of your slide window
if you cannot hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button at the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
this offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on a seee button located on the
bottom left-hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process of obtaining your
credit i'd now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Bobby Prince dr. Pratt is a
professor of a laboratory medicine and
pathology at the Mayo Clinic where she
serves as a co-director of the
vector-borne diseases laboratory
services she's received her metal degree
from the Robert Lerner College of
Medicine at the University of Vermont
and completed residency training and
ecology followed by a fellowship in
clinical microbiology she has been in
practice for almost ten years and is one
of 175 doctors at the Mayo Clinic who
specialized in pathology I now like to
turn the presentation over to dr. prett
welcome Thank You Suzy for that kind
introduction
so as Suzy mentioned I'm going to be
discussing Lyme disease today focusing
on molecular diagnostics and what is
available and how they can be used for
diagnosis of Lyme disease in conjunction
with other tests testing and then I'm
also going to touch on how they can be
used for detecting new causative agents
an area that I think is particularly
exciting now before we begin I'll just
say that my only disclosure is I am
employed by Mayo Clinic we offer some of
the tests that I will be mentioning
today for our detection of Lyme disease
so the overview of my talk is shown here
on this slide I'm going to start by
reviewing Lyme disease so that we're all
on the same page in terms of lyme
disease epidemiology and clinical
presentation i'm then going to overview
the testing methodologies that are
commonly used including serology which
is really our gold standard at this time
but then i'm going to get into molecular
techniques touch on what is in our
future for new molecular approaches and
then i'm going to finish by a case study
where we use molecular diagnostics for
detection of a new organism that causes
Lyme disease so let's talk about lyme
disease specifically it is caused by
bacteria that are transmitted by ticks
these bacteria are spirochetes and i've
shown these spiral-shaped organisms here
on the upper right hand corner of the
screen so this is what they look like
although they're microscopic and can't
be seen with the naked eye and they are
in this large complex called Borrelia
burgdorferi sensu lato complex the bit
of a mouthful it's a long name and it's
a group of organisms that are closely
related and many of them are capable of
causing Lyme disease in the United
States Borrelia burgdorferi sensu
stricto is the main cause of Lyme
disease and going forward for simplicity
I'm just going to call this Borrelia
burgdorferi so this is the main cause of
Lyme disease in the United States but
there are others Borrelia of zeliha
Borrelia grinia and Borrelia burgdorferi
cause lyme disease in europe and some of
these species have lyme disease in parts
of asia as well now looking at a bigger
picture i should mention that the
Borrelia species are even more
diverse then just the sensu lato complex
in fact there is a large group called
relapsing fever Borrelia species but I'm
only going to be discussing the Borrelia
burgdorferi sent to not too complex
today these are the species that include
agents of Lyme disease I won't be
getting into the relapsing fever
Borrelia that include Borrelia miyamotoi
which some of you may have heard of it's
been in the news recently and because
this is a test about a talk about
molecular diagnostics I also want to
give you a little basic background about
Borrelia burgdorferi it's genome sizes
shown here about 1 million five hundred
thousand base pairs and it's interesting
in that it has a linear chromosome and
it also has plasmids the linear
chromosome has a GC content of 28.6% and
then it has 21 plasmids of which 9 are
circular and 12 are linear so all
combined the linear chromosome and the
plasmids carry about 860 genes now let's
talk about the epidemiology of Lyme
disease this is an important disease
that many U of you are probably familiar
with it is the most common vector borne
illness in the United States and Europe
so anything transmitted by a vector that
would include insects and such as
mosquitoes and ticks of all of those
diseases Lyme is the most common now it
was first described in the United States
in 1975 associated with what was thought
at the time as a cluster of juvenile
rheumatoid rheumatoid arthritis cases
well it turns out that they weren't
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis they were
instead infection with Lyme disease now
Lyme does not occur nationwide in fact
it's concentrated in certain areas
specifically in the Northeast and the
upper Midwestern parts of the United
States and you can see that on the map
here on the bottom right where the
darker colors show the states that have
more cases of Lyme disease it's also
spreading up into Canada even though
that's not shown on this map and it
became a nationally notifiable disease
in 1990
so we've been able to track the number
of Lyme disease cases because they're
reported to the United the CDC the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention every year and so we have
some good data and I'm going to show you
some of that here on this map on this
slide is showing the reported cases of
Lyme disease starting in 2001 so every
blue dot on this map represents a
reported case of Lyme disease and the
dot is just placed randomly within a
county from where that case was reported
so now look and see as we scan through
different years 2001 2002 and as we
continue through note that the blue dots
are increasing a number and expanding
their range so now up to 2012 you can
see that there's an extensive portion of
the upper northeast that has a lot of
blue dots and the Upper Midwest
especially in Minnesota and Wisconsin
and from the data that we have there are
more than 30,000 cases reported each
year to the CDC but studies have shown
that the actual estimates are probably
closer to 300,000 cases each year and
I've provided the references for you on
the bottom of the screen so this is
based on data we have from reference
laboratories and also physician offices
now the vector for this bacterium is the
black legged tick and the main vector is
X OD scapularis sounds throughout much
of the United States on the west coast
it's the Western black legged tick EXO
DS Pacifica's this tick is relatively
small compared to some of the other
ticks you may have seen such as the dog
tick here are a number of ticks
different life cycle stages of the black
legged tick shown beside a dime but I
thought even for a better representation
I would use this example of a bagel so
we're all familiar with the everything
bagel with sesame seeds sunflower seeds
well our endive and poppy seeds I mean
and so the set
me seeds like this one here that's about
the size of an adult black legged dick
so that's an adult that's as big as it
gets until it starts feeding on blood
and that's what is going to potentially
be on you and what you'd want to keep an
eye out for now the nymphal stage which
can also transmit the agents that causes
Lyme disease is about the size of a
poppy seed so even smaller so you can
see how these would be very difficult to
detect especially before they start
feeding on blood and get bigger
now the lifecycle of exodia scapularis
is shown here this is from the CDC and
it's a two year life cycle it's pretty
complex and it goes through multiple
stages the larvae nymph and adult stages
and each stage has to take a blood meal
a blood meal is a way just to say it
feeds on another host it takes blood and
then it uses that blood to mold into the
next stage so let's start with the eggs
as circled here in red so the eggs are
laid in the spring by the female and the
female has over wintered essentially
hibernated under the leaf litter and has
stayed alive throughout the winter even
in our cold minnesota and northeastern
winners and survived to come out and lay
eggs these eggs will hatch into larvae
in the summer and these larvae are very
small they usually feed on small animals
such as birds and rodents those birds
and rodents may be infected with Lyme
disease so at this point that larvae can
now become infected with Lyme disease
itself the larvae will now molt into a
known but that won't happen until it's
over wintered so we are now in April and
the nymphal stages are just starting to
come out after a long winters
hibernation and they are potentially
infected with Lyme disease they are now
going to be searching for their next
blood meal and that could be on a larger
animal could be a deer could be a human
and at this point they can transmit
Borrelia burgdorferi to that human when
they feed so this is actually the
highest area of risk for human infection
the late spring and the summer because
these nymphs are very small the size of
a poppy seed and they are out looking
for a blood meal and they can bite us
and transmit and we can get Lyme disease
now they will then take their blood meal
and turn into adults that's the final
stage and these adults in the fall will
also be out looking for a blood meal and
so we often see a second peak of tick
borne diseases in the fall especially
for things such as anaplasmosis because
these adults also potentially infected
and capable of transmitting Lyme disease
are also out now biting humans they will
overwinter and they lay their eggs and
the life cycle continues now when these
different stages of ticks take a bite
and they start pumping their blood full
of are their body full of blood they
become engorged so this picture here
shows how on the left-hand side there is
an adult tick about the size of a sesame
seed that is not engorged but the middle
tick is partially engorged and the on
the right hand side this is a fully
engorged adult tick it's the same tick
it's just gotten significantly bigger
because it's now full of blood and now
the image above is showing a full tick
full of blood who is pregnant and she's
laying her eggs so this is happening
right about now these ticks are coming
out from under the leaf litter litter
after overwintering so who is at risk
for infection well essentially anyone
who's going outdoors but there are
certain areas where the ticks can be
found and so these black legged ticks
are found primarily in wooded areas tall
grasses leaf litter and they can't fly
that's important to know but they can
climb up on the vegetation and attach to
hosts as they as the hosts pass by
so people that tend to get exposed
would be people that are in the outdoors
like hikers bird watchers dog walkers
hunters and I showed a picture
in the upper right hand corner of a tick
that is extending its front legs and
this is a behavior called questing where
the ticks will hang out on the
vegetation wait for an animal or a human
to walk by and then grab on to their
clothing and then they will look for an
area of exposed skin and insert their
mouths cards and bite and take a blood
meal and at the same time potentially
inject organisms that cause disease such
as Borrelia burgdorferi so in addition
the Borrelia burgdorferi it's important
to mention there are other organisms
contained within the body of the tick
and those can also be transmitted to us
some are bacteria summer viruses summer
parasites so in the black legged tick we
have anaplasma phagocytes hasslein found
in 312 percent of ticks and endemic
areas Borrelia miyamotoi one of those
relapsing fever Borrelia and then the
virus Watson or deer tick virus and then
there's other things such as the BZ and
micro D and so a list of organisms the
bottom line here is that a single tick
bite can result in multiple infections
so prevention of tick bites is key now
what happens if someone gets Lyme
disease usually the first thing they
notice is the localized stage which is a
rash we call erythema migrans it's seen
in 70 to 80 percent of infected
individuals so that does mean that
twenty to thirty percent of individuals
won't have a rash at all and this rash
is shown by these two pictures here and
it is also described as target I'd or
like a bull's eye rash and you can see
where it would get the name bull's eye
because it has a red center with an
external clearing and then another red
line so it looks like a big target or a
big bullseye
so this erythema migrans rash is very
classic if this is seen this is
diagnostic of Lyme disease in an endemic
setting and physicians will treat based
on this no laboratory testing is
necessary now these patients may have
other symptoms or all they may have is
this rash and this rash could be easily
overlooked if it's someplace not easily
seen such as
back or the scalp other symptoms these
patients may have though include a flute
a flute like syndrome with malaise
headache and fever and possibly
lymphadenopathy now if disease is not
caught at this point it will progress in
most patients and it will progress to
what we call an early disseminated stage
days two weeks after that tick bite that
could result in more erythema migrans
lesions so more of those target I'd
rashes
it can cause Bell's palsy which is a
paralysis on one side of the face
usually temporary but can last for quite
some time it can also cause more serious
manifestations such as meningitis
encephalitis and even fatal arrhythmias
myocarditis and pericarditis so early
recognition and treatment is key you do
not want to get into this stage with
disease progression
now if Lyme disease is not treated at
this point it will continue to progress
and this is the late disseminated stage
this happens months to years after the
tick bite the most common symptom at
this stage is arthritis it's
intermittent and it usually is
unilateral can be bilateral and it
causes severe joint pain and swelling of
large joints especially the knees as is
shown in this picture here by the CDC
other important complications could be
neurologic symptoms numbness tingling in
the hands and feet difficulty with
short-term memory these individuals have
a hard time focusing and being
functional in their jobs and then some
of the species especially those found in
Europe have some unique manifestations
Borrelia grinia is more likely to have
neurologic manifestations where Borrelia
of Zelly i has a unique skin condition
called acrid Irma Titus chronic atrophic
ins so clearly we want to recognize and
treat Lyme disease early on and avoid
these symptoms
now treatment early disease with
erythema migrans is usually treated with
doxycycline or another antibiotic for 14
to 21 days the later stage
are often more aggressively treated with
intravenous antibiotics such as
ceftriaxone the problem comes in with
this syndrome which is called
post-treatment Lyme disease syndrome
this is lingering symptoms after what is
considered to be adequate treatment this
is seen in ten to twenty percent of
individuals and they will persist with
myalgias arthralgias cognitive defects
sleep disturbance fatigue we don't
entirely know the cause it's postulated
that it may be an autoimmune response to
the organism and so the organism is not
thought to still be present there's no
evidence at this point that this is an
ongoing infection but instead it's of
the bodies it's the host response to the
previous infection so this is a very
challenging area for treatment diagnosis
if it is not in that early stage with
that classic rash if that is not present
then the classic recommended therapy
recommended by the CDC is this
two-tiered serology testing algorithm
and essentially as you can see here on
the screen this starts with an Eliza so
an enzyme linked immunosorbent assay
testing for antibodies to Lyme disease
and if it is positive or equivocal then
we perform a confirmatory immunoblot
looking for antibodies in IgM and IgG
class and it depends on the timing and
how strong the diagnosis is suspected as
to whether additional samples are tested
and how the diagnosis is made so this is
fine and it has some problems in
challenges related to the fact that it's
serology in and of itself and antibodies
aren't often detectable in the first
week of illness and but it is a good
standard method for diagnosis but
because it's not perfect we've been
looking for other ways to diagnose Lyme
disease and at this point molecular
detection comes in as a possible
adjunctive or even alternate test so
molecular detection allows for a direct
detection of the organisms
nucleic acid and so whether that's DNA
or RNA you're detecting the organism
directly or a piece of the organism
rather than the patient's host response
now it tends to be positive earlier on
before serology and again the
development of antibodies can take two
to three weeks there are a variety of
nucleic acid amplification tests or nets
that have been described unfortunately
and none of them are currently
fda-approved so instead these are
laboratory developed tests they aren't
easily available in kits for other
people to use
so there's limited availability usually
at specialized reference centers most of
them use polymerase chain reaction or
PCR and common targets are listed here
the 16s rRNA gene flagellin gene Osprey
SC looking for an amplicon size of about
100 to 300 base pairs and these are
performed on a number of different
specimen types Sno vo fluids synovium
skin biopsies straight brow spinal fluid
and whole blood now let's talk a little
bit about PCR in specifically real-time
PCR because this is the most common
method that is used for detection of
Lyme disease so as most of you probably
know fluorescent probes are used to
detect the DNA and the DNA is detected
as it is amplified unlike conventional
PCR where you don't detect the DNA until
the whole reaction is finished and so
this can be very sensitive and specific
if designed correctly and it can be semi
quantitative because the sooner the
amplicon is detected the higher the
amount of DNA that's present in the
patient specimens if you want to do
absolute quantification that can also be
done with an addition of a calibration
curve although that's not routinely done
for clinical Diagnostics
so usually real-time PCR semi
quantitative detection is used now in my
laboratory we use a method called
melting curve analysis which is a
modification of real-time PCR it occurs
after amplification
it can use nonspecific DNA binding dyes
or specific probes we prefer specific
probes because it's more specific and it
has the additional benefit of detecting
mutations or possibly even new organisms
so in this next slide here I have an
example of the assay that we use in my
laboratory this is our Lyme disease PCR
it detects all of the members of the
Borrelia burgdorferi sensu lato complex
it targets the plasminogen binding
protein up a1 and it uses fret probes
fluorescent residents energy transfer
probes for a melting temperature
analysis stage after DNA has been
amplified and we use differences in the
probe region in fact there are two base
pair differences to be able to
distinguish Borrelia burgdorferi from
Borrelia of zeliha and Borrelia grinny i
and this base pair difference shows up
on a melting temperature analysis as two
separate melting Peaks so this is a
method that some laboratories use we use
it in my laboratory and it's nice
because you can use a single probe in
primer set and be able to detect and
differentiate related organisms now what
are the disadvantages of PCR why are we
still using serology if we have PCR for
early and sensitive detection well the
problem is is even though the test can
be sensitive it is not sensitive in the
specific specimens in the host it has a
low sensitivity I should say a clinical
sensitivity for detecting acute
infection and that's just because
there's not a lot of DNA present in
specimens that we test such as whole
blood so for example blood is only
positive in about 50% of cases of
patients with an erythema migrans rash
so what we would say what we would
consider to be confirmed
acute Lyme disease these patients have
the erythema migrans rash and yet blood
is only positive and half of those so
that's not a very good test performance
also cerebral spinal fluid is positive
and only about 1/3 of patients with
confirmed early infection neuro
borreliosis or limes
involving the central nervous system it
also doesn't distinguish between live
and dead organisms and we know that dead
organisms can remain especially in
confined spaces like the joint space so
there have been studies showing DNA
persist after successful treatment in
the joint space up to six months and the
persistence does not correlate with
duration of symptoms or risk of relapse
in Lyme arthritis so you can detect DNA
in a Lyme patient infected with Lyme
disease in joint fluid so synovial fluid
and that doesn't necessarily mean the
patient is still infected the patient
could be successfully treated so these
are limitations of Lyme disease PCR and
therefore the way we use it is really as
an adjunctive test not routinely as a
part of Lyme disease diagnosis it's good
for confirming infection when you have a
typical clinical manifestations and the
primary specimen types that are tested
our skin biopsies and synovial fluid or
synovium tissue and in these specimens
PCR actually has a relatively good
sensitivity greater than 90% on synovial
fluid if patients have untreated or
partially treated Lyme disease and also
quite good in skin lesions from an
erythema migrans the sensitivity is
anywhere between 36 to 88% now we're
talking single plaques PCR where you're
looking for a single organism but
remember I said that those ticks can be
infected with multiple organisms and
they can transmit them to humans so it
would be preferable if we could detect
all the things that a person could get
from a single tick bite so multiplex
molecular panels these are on the market
already where you have multiple primers
sometimes probes depending on the system
for detection of a number of organisms
that share a common clinical
presentation or common exposure risk so
there are already tests that are
approved or cleared by the Food and Drug
Administration for gastrointestinal
disease meningitis and stuff
this positive blood cultures and
respiratory pathogens now at this point
there are not any panels for tick-borne
disease available commercially
but there are some under development so
I think in the next five years or so we
will expect to see commercially
available fda-approved or clear tests
that are panel borne tests for tick
borne diseases now the problem of course
you're still using specific primers and
probes so you're only going to detect
the organism you're you're targeting and
non targeted organisms will be missed so
taking a step beyond this this is
partially overcome by use of broad range
sequencing and this is where you
sequence a specific gene that will cover
a range of organisms so for example the
16s rRNA gene is common to most bacteria
and so if you amplify that gene and then
sequence it to detect what is present I
apologize for this and so if you then to
sequence what you've amplified then you
can use this to detect a number of
different organisms and then say what
they are and you're not using and you're
not going to miss organisms that have
the 16s rRNA gene so this is a promising
approach that is one step beyond
multiplex molecular tests now the next I
will mention that I'm particularly
excited about is meta genomic testing
this takes it even beyond one step of
targeted gene amplification and
sequencing with metagenomics you are
amplifying all of the nucleic acid in a
specimen and that could be bacterial
fungal viral parasitic and of course
human DNA will be in there as well
and that's important for tick-borne
diseases because you have lyme disease
which is trans which is a bacterium
Borrelia burgdorferi that causes that
disease but then you have viral
pathogens also transmitted by ticks and
you have parasitic pathogens so with
meta genomic analysis you could
potentially detect all of those now at
this point because there's so much RNA
and B
des extensive pre and post-processing
steps are used to select for your
targets of interest and remove non
relevant nucleic acid and the
bioinformatics of this is quite complex
and therefore this is currently very
expensive and time-consuming but I think
this is bound to change in the future
and we're going to see potentially in
the next five or ten years diagnostic
assays used to detect tick borne
diseases and other syndromes now I'm
going to shift gears and talk about a
specific case study where we used our
fret based assay with multi temperature
analysis to detect a new cause of Lyme
disease which we have called Borrelia
may only I and this is a novel cause of
Lyme disease in the United States now
I'm going to tell you the story and to
do that I have to set the national stage
and so note Minnesota and Wisconsin are
highlighted in red in the Upper Midwest
and the story began in June of 2013 with
a little boy who was from the
northwestern part of Minnesota as shown
by the yellow star on this map he
presented with fever headache neck pain
myalgia nausea and vomiting he also had
a diffuse rash and profound somnolence
so inability to easily be roused he was
very very sleepy so much but his parents
brought into the emergency room and he
was actually admitted to the hospital
because of his profound somnolence and a
syndrome with other symptoms now he has
spent the week prior in Spooner
Wisconsin which is shown by this other
gold star on the map right over next in
the state next door this is a picture of
the little boy in his hospital bed and
it's just to illustrate the rash which
you can see is not that bullseye rash
that I showed you earlier but instead
what we would describe as a
maculopapular rash which is diffused
variably sized and involves his trunk
and his extremities interestingly it
also involved his palms and soles so not
a classic Lyme disease present
this was the summertime and so they
tried to do abroad work up in this
little boy and one of the things that
was ordered was our Lyme disease PCR and
this was ordered on a whole blood
specimen now remember I told you before
that whole blood is not a very sensitive
specimen to test for detecting Lyme
disease well in this case it's a good
thing they ordered it because instead of
seeing a melting temperature peak for
one of the known pathogens Borrelia of
Zelly eye grinning ir burgdorferi
we instead saw this peak in the middle
this was our patient result so it was a
clear positive it was reproducible and
yet it clearly fell outside of the range
of the known organisms that our assay
looks for but because this test detects
all the members of the Borrelia
burgdorferi sensu lato complex we were
pretty sure that this was a member of
the complex it just wasn't a member that
we were familiar with now this patient
did eventually recover he was
hospitalized for a total of four days he
was treated with antibiotics and
thankfully made a full recovery so as we
were investigating this he got better
and was released but meanwhile we
started seeing additional cases so this
was just not a one-off case in fact we
had another PCR positive in whole blood
with the same atypical melting
temperature peak in an 11-year old male
from Wisconsin and this was just the
following month so this prompted us to
do a retrospective review of our
previous positives maybe we had missed
some of these they would have been
reported out as a positive result and we
would have called it an atypical
positive result but now that we knew
what to look for with this melting
temperature peak right in the middle
between the two other Peaks we could go
back to our previous PCR runs and see if
we had seen this before well sure enough
our retrospective review showed that the
year prior we had a 65 year old male
from North Dakota although he had likely
took exposure in Minnesota and he also
had the same peak and this was all
detected in whole blood we
reached out to our colleagues our sister
labs throughout Minnesota and Wisconsin
that are also performing this assay and
share enough Mayo Clinic Eau Claire
reported detecting the same atypical
peak in a synovial fluid specimen and
this was a 21 year old woman from
Wisconsin and this was in that same
month of June 2013 when this all started
so we had four patients and then over
the next month we detected an additional
two patients so at this point we were
getting pretty excited so I'm going to
talk about the molecular workup of how
you investigate a new species
once you've detected something and one
of the first things we did is we
sequenced it we sequenced our
plasminogen binding protein gene and
then we also sequenced the 16s rRNA gene
and the 16s rRNA gene sequence is shown
here with the phylogenetic tree and
patient five and six are highlighted
with the red arrow now I just want to
point out that the red box shows
Borrelia burgdorferi the known cause of
lyme disease in the United States and
you can see that the DNA detected in
patients five and six are clearly
different than Borrelia burgdorferi with
a good separation between them so we
were pretty sure that this was not our
standard Borrelia burgdorferi so at this
point we were communicating with our
Minnesota Department of Health and our
Wisconsin Department of Health we also
reached out for assistance to our
colleagues at the CDC in Fort Collins
Colorado and a full investigation was
undertaken we had blood that we obtained
from two patients we sent that for
culture of the organism we also did
sequencing both of the CDC and at Mayo
Clinic and so here are some of our
results first of all it was very
exciting to see that on dark field
microscopy we could see spirochetes
swimming in the blood of our infected
patients and we could quantitate them it
was about 85,000 spirochetes per
milliliter of blood again this is very
unusual because as I had mentioned
earlier
disease is not usually detectable by
blood
because Borrelia burgdorferi is not
present in any significant number and
spirochetes of Borrelia burgdorferi
have never been detected by dark field
microscopy so being able to actually see
them was very exciting and very unusual
we also were able to grow them in a
culture using modified bsk media and we
saw a modal spirochetes we were able to
propagate those spirochetes so we're
starting to fulfill some of Koch's
postulates on implicating this as the
cause of the patient's symptoms and and
lastly we did multi locus sequence
analysis and this is a form of
amplification where you amplify multiple
genes and then through this analysis you
can compare to other Borrelia
burgdorferi sensu lato gino species and
see how similar your organism is to
known organisms so this was previously
used for defining Borrelia burgdorferi
sensu lato gino species and i put the
reference for you at the bottom of the
screen now the highest similarity was to
Borrelia burgdorferi but the cutoff for
separating gino species is anything less
than 98.3%
so at the closest pairwise similarity we
were at about 95% so clearly less than
98% and this confirmed that this was a
novel Borrelia burgdorferi I send salatu
genus species we proposed the name
Borrelia me oniy I after the name of the
Mayo brothers who found at Mayo Clinic
and this name has now been accepted
formally so let's look at a breakdown of
all the patients that we've tested to
date since we've been performing our
real-time PCR assay for Lyme disease
since 2003 we've tested a lot of
specimens and at Mayo Clinic we are an
international reference laboratory so we
test patient specimens from all over the
United States
so between 2003 and 2014 we tested over
a hundred thousand patient specimens
now let's break them down by timeframe
so if we look at anything before 2012
from 2003 to 2011 we tested over 66,000
patient specimens and none of them
detected Borrelia maoli I and so you can
see a no Borrelia me oniy i positive and
that was reflected by the lack of us
seeing any of these atypical melting
Peaks as shown in the upper right hand
corner and we didn't go back and retest
specimens this was just analyzing
previous runs from all of these other
years now let's look at the right hand
column from 2012 when we first detected
that first case up until September 2014
which is when we concluded our
investigation we had tested nearly
34,000 patient specimens during that
two-year time frame and we only detected
six cases from patients that were
residents of Minnesota Wisconsin or
North Dakota
now patients from 44 other states other
than Minnesota Wisconsin and North
Dakota did not yield any Borrelia me
only i positives so how did we interpret
this well it looks like Borrelia may
oniy i is only found in the upper
midwest and it was not detected in our
laboratory prior to 2012 and perhaps it
just wasn't at levels that were high
enough for us to be detecting it and it
could have still been in the wild but as
a human disease it looks like it's newly
emergent and it looks like it's
geographically confined to the Upper
Midwest and what do we see with these
six patients well they had a span of
Ages anywhere from 10 to 67 years the
majority were males and that reflects
what we usually see with Lyme disease
probably because males are more likely
to be outside and exposed to tick bites
five percent with an acute febrile
illness and interestingly three had
potential neurologic involvement that
included confused speech profound
somnolence visual difficulties and this
is unusual for Lyme disease early on
this
a bit concerning that 50% of our
patients had this potential complication
four patients had a rash but unlike that
erythema migrans rash that I had
described to you before actually most
patients had an atypical rash like our
young boy our first patient in fact only
one patient had a rash that could be
called definitively an erythema migrans
rash and that is important to note
because physicians use that rash to
diagnose early Lyme disease and then
prescribe antibiotics now we did have
one patient who had arthralgias so joint
involvement was seen with this organism
infection and all of our patients
reported exposure to ticks or tick
habitats
five recovered with antibiotics but our
one patient with arthralgia continued to
have joint pain after our two years of
follow-up now serologic testing was done
on these patients and as I mentioned
earlier this is considered the gold
standard preferred diagnostic for Lyme
disease and how did it do well it seemed
to be performing as expected so for
example patient number one when we
collected serum
six days after illness onset you can see
that the EIA for c6 was positive and the
confirmatory immunoblot was positive for
IgM so this would be considered a
positive result but as I mentioned the
limitations with serology is that it
takes a few days to develop a detectable
immune response so let's look at patient
number three the first specimen we had
from patient number three was detected
was collected only two days after
illness onset and that was essentially a
negative result but the next specimen we
collected from patient number three was
29 days after illness onset and that was
now positive so patients are developing
an immune response but as we know with
serology it's not going to be detectable
early on and so I have all of the
patients here we were able to have
serologic tests performed on all of our
patients except for
one now we also did some additional
testing looking for a vector this is not
something we normally do in a clinical
laboratory we don't usually go out and
test ticks for tick borne pathogens but
in this case we wanted to know was it
indeed the black legged tick xod
scapularis that was transmitting
Borrelia Mei Mei
so we teamed up with some partners in
Wisconsin and here are a couple of the
colleagues they are looking at a white
sheet that they have dragged over
vegetation the ticks as I mentioned will
climb up on the vegetation and extend
their legs and then they will grab on as
objects walk by or move by and in this
case they grab onto a white sheet that
white sheet is then carefully examined
and ticks are removed they're identified
put into vials and then brought back to
the laboratory in this case we brought
them back to my laboratory and we
performed a very simple physical
disruption of the tick we did this with
a scalpel blade you can also do this
with beads through bead beading and we
tested each tick individually but you
can also test ticks in pulls pulls the
five pulls of ten we wanted to get down
to the individual tick level at this
case after we chopped them up we
digested them with proteinase k then we
extracted the DNA and performed our PCR
sa as if it was a normal clinical
specimen and what did we find
well this these are the results of our
PCR testing of ticks that we had
collected prospectively as well as some
archived specimens and the map in the
upper right hand corner shows the area
where we collected these ticks from and
I will highlight the main results here
so Borrelia may only I out of the adult
exodia scapularis that we tested
approximately three percent were
positive for brow EMA only I now I want
to compare that to the column right next
to it where Borrelia burgdorferi
was detected in 34% of our adult
exodia scapularis so three percent
versus thirty four percent clearly
Borrelia burgdorferi is the passage
and that you want to watch out for here
but Borrelia Mayo kneei is also present
and then we test it nymphal ticks and
that was detected in 2.1 percent so all
in all we had an overall detection rate
of 2.9 percent of our exodia ticks that
we tested
so the major findings and conclusions
from this analysis largely which was
performed using molecular techniques are
shown on the subsequent slides so first
features number one that I would
consider to be a remarkable feature if
that brilliant Leone eye causes Lyme
disease in the Upper Midwest and this
map with all the blue dots on it shows
all of the sights of different
laboratories that send specimens to my
lab for testing and you can see that we
are very well represented in the
Northeast we have a lot of laboratories
that send specimens to us and out of
nearly 25,000 specimens just within that
two-year time frame that were from all
of these other sites we did not detect
Borrelia may Oni I so we think that this
really is geographically isolated or
limited to the Upper Midwest remarkable
feature number two patients with
beryllium a Oni eye infection have to
date had more severe disease than lyme
disease caused by Borrelia burgdorferi
we had potential neurologic involvement
three patients illness requiring
hospitalization and two of our patients
and interestingly nausea and vomiting
were common symptoms and that's not
typically seen in Lyme disease I believe
we will need further studies to really
better define the spectrum of illness in
patients infected with Borrelia Mayo
kneei it could be that we're just
detecting the most severe cases and that
there are many more cases of mild
disease that are going unnoticed and
undiagnosed remarkable feature number
three the rashes as I have explained
were more diffuse with only one patient
having a classic erythema migrans lesion
and again this is important because
physicians are using the rash as a
diagnostic feature so physicians have to
be aware that with Borelli and they only
eye
Raschi looks different remarkable
picture number four it has been found
predominantly in whole blood which as I
mentioned earlier is not common for
Borrelia burgdorferi but we now think
that pcr on whole blood may be the
preferred method for detecting Borrelia
Mayo kneei and that's a paradigm shift
for this organism as I mentioned
historically less than 0.1% of blood
specimens have been positive for
Borrelia burgdorferi that's probably
different for Borrelia Mei Mei so if you
want to read the details of our study
they were published in The Lancet
Infectious Diseases
and I want to give credit to all of the
other individuals that are listed here
this was a multi-site collaboration with
our state universities local state
health departments and the CDC we've
since published additional papers and
you may be interested in some of them
here the first paper was published in
the International Journal of systemic
and evolutionary microbiology that is
how we confirmed the name Borrelia Mei
Mei so this is now an accepted name and
then we also published the whole genome
sequence and comparative genomics in
plus one in 2016 so with that I'd like
to conclude with this last slide that
just acknowledges that this was a
tremendous team effort with many many
individuals and so I was very honored to
be a part of that and this was all using
molecular diagnostics for Lyme disease
so it was a very exciting adventure so
with that I would like to turn this back
over to our hosts and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you so much
for your presentation dr. prett we do
want to get right into the questions and
input so here's a reminder as to how
audience members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at that lower left if we are
unable to get to your questions due to
time constraints dr. prick will be
answering submitted questions via email
so let's begin with our first question
dr. Pierre an audience member would like
to know what are the best measure
for preventing ticket rates that's a
great question
because you're probably after watching
this presentation worried about even
going outside and tics are around us in
many parts of the country so the best
thing is to take some simple
preventative measures as I mentioned
early on tics are found and tall but
tall shrubs and bushes and grasses and
in the leaf litter so just taking simple
steps such as avoiding the edges of a
path if you're going hiking stay to the
middle of the path
and avoid the tall grasses where the
ticks may be now of course that's not
always feasible sometimes you just want
to go out into the great outdoors and
walk through the woods and the grasses
so in that case you want to wear a tick
repellent such as deep and you just
spray that on exposed skin you can also
use permethrin on your clothing and then
weather permitting you can also just
give the ticks less skin that they could
potentially grab on to by wearing
long-sleeved shirts and long pants and
by tucking your pants into your socks
and and wearing a hat and all of these
again this clothing can be treated with
permethrin so those are just some simple
steps to avoid tick bite okay thank you
so much a little bit of a similar
question another person wants to do what
should I do if I find a tick on myself
oh yeah that's that's a great question
as well and I should have mentioned
earlier that one of the most important
things you can do when you come in from
being outdoors is to do a tick check and
when you do that tick check you want to
carefully check your whole body
including your scalp and you want to
check your children and your pets and
your other friends and family members
for ticks and you may come across the
tick that is crawling on you in which
case you can just grab it and flush it
down the toilet but if it's embedded in
you then you're going to want to remove
it and you're going to want to remove it
as quickly as possible so longer the
tick is attached the greater the
likelihood it can transmit
disease-causing organisms the best way
to remove it is to use fine tip tweezers
just grab the tick
by the base of close to the skin as you
can and pull it out in a single
continuous motion you don't want to
twist the tick you don't want to squash
the tick you don't want to damage
yourself or the tick because that may
increase the risk of infection and so
some of you may have heard of some home
remedies like using a matchstick to burn
the tick and yes that will work but it
may also increase the risk of infection
and you may also hurt yourself at the
same time petroleum jelly also works but
again the goal is to remove the tick as
quickly as possible so you want to avoid
things that take a while you just want
to take the tick off of you and remove
it intact
wonderful we have some incredible
questions coming in here's one do I
always need to see a doctor when I find
a tick attacked
I'm sorry attached to myself yeah that's
important especially if you live in an
area with a lot of ticks you'd be going
to the doctor all the time although
hopefully you're taking those
preventative measures I mentioned and
not getting ticks on you but if you do
get a tick on you and it's been attached
you don't necessarily need to go to the
doctor but here's a few general
guidelines if the tick has been attached
for more than 36 hours and you may be
able to tell that just by how swollen or
engorge the tick is if it's very
engorged that means it's probably been
attached for 36 hours then I would say
yes if you live in an area with a lot of
Lyme disease you should remove the tick
put it in a ziploc or plastic bag and
then go to your physician and tell them
you found this tick if the tick ends up
being a black leggett tick then you are
at risk for having Lyme disease and your
physician may give you an antibiotic
such as doxycycline to prevent Lyme
disease
now if the kick doesn't look like it's
swollen and you think it's only been
attached for a short period of time then
the recommendations are to remove the
tick you can keep it in a plastic bag or
you can flush it down the toilet you
want to wash the area carefully wash
your hands and then you're just going to
want to watch that area look for a rash
and watch for other symptoms of tick
borne diseases such as fever myalgias
full and lymph nodes and if you see any
of those symptoms then you should go to
the doctor you can bring the tick with
you and you can tell them that you did
have this tick bite but you don't
necessarily have to go to the doctor
each time you have a tick bite well this
is so interesting we have one question
times of one more question are there any
molecular Lyme disease tests in the
pipeline that would be FDA approved yeah
that would that's a great question and
fortunately the answer is yes there are
many tests that are in the pipeline I
don't know if any of them will go all
the way through to FDA clearance or
approval for in vitro diagnostic use but
that is the goal and so I know of
several companies working on tests using
PCR and also additional technologies
besides polymerase chain reaction and
those have shown promise for maybe being
more sensitive and so I think it would
be great to have a more sensitive
molecular diagnostic test especially for
that early stage that first week of
illness when antibodies aren't
necessarily detectable that you can have
sensitive and specific detection of
Borrelia burgdorferi and other related
organisms causing Lyme so I think we
should all keep a close eye on the
market and talk to some of our vendor
colleagues and find out what they're
working on and maybe even partner with
them to help them develop their tests
because I think there really is a need
for it and I'm very hopeful that in the
next five years we'll see some tests on
the market it would be great thank you
again dr. Britt this is an amazing
presentation as give me final comments
before we end this presentation no I
just you know it's spring now so
everyone go out enjoy the outdoors but
also take those measures to avoid tick
bites great thank you so much dr. prett
I'd like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through
July 2017 keep an eye out for an emails
and lab routes alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
also want to encourage you to forward
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event thank
you again for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye
you